en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre los
receptores acoplados a la proteína g
también conocidos como gps r los
receptores acoplados a proteínas que
sólo se encuentran en eucariotas y
forman parte de la clase más grande
conocida de receptores de membrana de
hecho los humanos tienen más de 1000
tipos diferentes de gps reconocidos y
cada uno es específico para una función
en particular son receptores de membrana
muy particulares y son el objetivo de
alrededor del 30 al 50 por ciento de
todos los fármacos modernos los ligandos
que se unen van desde cosas como
compuestos sensibles a la luz hasta
olores feromonas hormonas e incluso
neurotransmisores los gpcr pueden
regular el sistema inmunitario el
crecimiento el sentido del olfato del
gusto de la vista conducta y nuestro
estado de ánimo incluyendo cosas como la
serotonina y la dopamina e incluso ahora
muchas proteínas g&g pcr todavía tienen
funciones desconocidas y es un tema muy
investigado de hecho sólo en 2012 se
otorgó el premio nobel de química por la
en gps para comenzar hablemos un poco
sobre la estructura de los gps r es
imposible tener una discusión sobre el
funcionamiento de los gps r sin tener
una comprensión de cómo se ven la
característica más importante de los gps
r es que tienen siete hélices alfa
transmembrana si consideramos que esta
es la membrana celular este es el lado
extracelular y este es el lado
intracelular si tenemos un gps r un
receptor acoplado a proteínas atravesará
esta membrana 7 veces
digamos que comienza aquí y tenemos 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 esta es una de las
características más importantes de un
gps r tienen 7 hélices alfa
transmembrana dado que esta es una
característica estructural tan única e
interesante a menudo también llamamos a
los gpcr receptores transmembrana de
siete dominios etiquetamos rápidamente
este gp cr aquí como su nombre lo indica
gpcr interactúa con las proteínas
están acoplados con proteínas que ahora
es importante también hablar un poco
sobre la estructura de las proteínas g
las proteínas que en general son
proteínas especializadas que tienen la
capacidad de unirse a gtp y gp en otras
palabras pueden unirse al trifosfato de
guanosina y al di fosfato de guanosina
de ahí el nombre de proteínas g ahora
algunas proteínas que son proteínas
pequeñas con subunidad única sin embargo
cuando hablamos de gps r todas las
proteínas g que se asocian con gpcr son
hetero tri américas es decir que tienen
tres subunidades diferentes tres
secciones voy a dibujar esto la primera
subunidad o sección de esta proteína la
llamamos subunidad alfa a la segunda le
llamamos beta y a la tercera la llamamos
gamma alfa beta y gamma juntas son
nuestra proteína g notarán que dibuje la
subunidades alfa y gamma con una pequeña
cola en la membrana celular y las
razones por qué estas dos subunidades
alfa y gamma están unidas a la membrana
celular por lo que ya
anclajes lipídicos lo último sobre esta
imagen que necesito dibujar es nuestro
gtp como recordamos el objetivo de una
proteína g es unirse a gtp gp en este
momento de esta proteína está inactiva y
por lo tanto se une al gp el di fosfato
de guanosina este gp se une a la
subunidad alfa cuando esta proteína se
active y hablaremos en un momento como
sucede esto se unirá a gtp ya que
dibujamos una imagen de la proteína g
hablemos un poco sobre como sucede en
nuestra vía de señalización el objetivo
de los receptores de membrana es que
responden a las moléculas de
señalización y ligando y responden al
medio ambiente como mencionamos antes
los receptores acoplados a la proteína g
interactúan con una amplia variedad de
moléculas en la superficie externa de
las células cada receptor generalmente
se une a una o unas pocas moléculas muy
específicas que se acoplan como una
cerradura y una llave si suponemos que
nuestra molécula de señalización es un
círculo como éste
la forma en el gps ere con la que se
unirá deberá ser complementaria cuando
esta molécula de señalización verde se
une al gpcr el gps r sufrirá lo que
llamamos un cambio de conformación la
forma de éste gpcr cambiará lo que a su
vez desencadenará una compleja sucesión
de eventos que finalmente influirá en
las diferentes funciones celulares como
mencionamos el primer paso aquí es por
supuesto el ligando la molécula de
señalización tiene que unirse al gps r
una vez que este ligando se une el gps r
sufrirá un cambio de conformación vamos
a dibujar de nuevo el gpcr 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
las 7 hélices alfa es un poco más
difícil dibujar un cambio de
conformación pero la proteína en
realidad se verá completamente diferente
aquí debido a esta unión tendremos un
cambio de conformación la conformación
de la proteína de un gpcr se alterará
vamos a escribir los primeros dos pasos
muy rápido paso 1
tenemos el ligando que se une al gen
pcr paso 2 dijimos que ocurre un cambio
de conformación el gps r sufre un cambio
de conformación
lo que ocurre después es que debido a
este cambio de conformación la subunidad
alfa que voy a dibujar aquí va a cambiar
este gp por gtp el paso 3 es que la sub
unidad alfa intercambia el gp por gtp la
molécula se intercambia y en lugar de gp
tenemos gtp ahora debido a que tenemos
gtp unido a esta subunidad alfa para que
la subunidad alfa se disocie y se aleje
de las subunidades beta y gamma una vez
que esto sucede estas dos secciones
diferentes la subunidad alfa y el dinero
beta gamma estos dos juntos encontraran
una proteína en la membrana esto va a
alterar y regular la función de esa
proteína podríamos tener otra proteína
por ejemplo aquí que la subunidad alfa
encontrará y cuya función regulará vamos
a escribir esto paso 4 la subunidad alfa
se disocia y regula las proteínas
objetivo ahora durante este paso hay
algunas cosas que me gustaría que
tuviéramos en cuenta
la primera es que tanto la subunidad
alfa como el número beta gamma pueden
interactuar con otras proteínas para
transmitir mensajes nos centraremos en
la subunidad alfa
porque tiende a ser más común sin
embargo la subunidades beta gamma
también pueden regular las funciones de
otras proteínas las proteínas objetivos
pueden ser enzimas que producen segundos
mensajeros de los que hablaremos un poco
más en un momento o canales iónicos que
también permiten que los iones sean
segundos mensajeros como mencionamos las
proteínas que son increíblemente
diversas algunas proteínas que pueden
estimular la actividad mientras que
otras también pueden inhibir la ahora
paso 5 una vez que esta sub unidad alfa
activa una proteína objetivo esta
proteína objetivo puede transmitir una
señal
mientras que esté ligando esté unido al
gps en este proceso donde la subunidad
alfa se disocia busca una proteína
objetivo y la regula y causa una cadena
completa de eventos puede ocurrir
repetidamente siempre y cuando esté
ligando esté unido como podemos hacer
que esto vuelva a la normalidad
bueno el paso 6 es que el gtp se
hidroliza gp el gtp pierde un fosfato en
la hidrólisis y se convierte en gp una
vez que esto sucede todo vuelve a la
normalidad el ligando se irá y todo
volverá a ser como estaba y quedará
listo para combinarse con otro ligando
en el futuro esto a menudo sucede sólo
eventualmente el gtp se hidroliza y se
convertirá en gp aunque nuestro cuerpo
tiene algunas formas de regular esto una
forma común es la proteína rgs14 la
señalización por proteínas y esto puede
acelerar este paso ahora que conocemos
los pasos veamos un ejemplo un ejemplo
muy común de la función gps
en la célula implica epinefrina o
adrenalina esta es nuestra respuesta de
lucha o huida supongamos que este
ligando verde esta molécula de
señalización verde es epinefrina y
supongamos que el gpr es nuestro
receptor adrenérgico una vez que esta
epinefrina se une al receptor
adrenérgico al gpcr en nuestro cuerpo
que sea una ley pone fin a este receptor
adrenérgico sufrirá un cambio de
conformación cambiará de gp en esta sub
unidad alfa por gtp y ésta subunidad
alfa
ahora buscará otra proteína y regulará
su función y sucede que la proteína que
busca será a demi la tos y clase ahora
tenemos la adenilato ciclasa activada y
estimulada por la subunidad alpha lo que
hará laden y la tos y clase es que
tomara atp trifosfato de adenosina y
producirá mp mono fosfato de adenosina
cíclico quitará dos fosfatos de nuestro
trifosfato y lo convertirá en mono
fosfato una vez que esto sucede nuestro
adn
es lo que llamamos un segundo mensajero
nuestra señal o epinefrina pasa por todo
este proceso y la señal se transforma en
otra señal en la mp cíclico que ahora
está dentro de nuestra célula
le dirá a la célula que haga otras cosas
por ejemplo el que aumente nuestra
frecuencia cardíaca también dilatar a
nuestros vasos sanguíneos del músculo
esquelético recordemos que es pelear o
huir necesitamos comenzar a correr o
pelear por lo que los músculos van a
dilatar sus vasos sanguíneos finalmente
todo este proceso requerirá mucha
energía por lo que vamos a descomponer
el glucógeno en glucosa
recuerden que este es nuestro grupo más
grande de receptores de membrana celular
es un proceso bastante complicado
repasemos lo de nuevo por ejemplo la
epinefrina se une al gpcr este gpcr
cambia su forma y sufre un cambio de
conformación cambia el gp a gtp en la
subunidad alfa lo que hace que la
subunidad alfa se disocie y busque
regular otra proteína y esta proteína
convertirá el atp en a mp cíclico que es
nuestro segundo mensajero y este segundo
mensajero le dirá al cuerpo que haga
otras cosas por ejemplo aumentar la
frecuencia cardíaca dilatar los vasos
sanguíneos descomponer el glucógeno en
glucosa ahora otros gpcr en nuestro
cuerpo los otros mil van a hacer otras
cosas pero se someterán a un proceso
similar en resumen los gpcr son una
familia grande y diversa de receptores
de superficie celular que responden a
muchas señales externas diferentes la
unión de la molécula de señalización
obligando al gpcr da como resultado la
activación de la proteína
que luego desencadena la producción de
otros segundos mensajeros con esta
secuencia de eventos los gpcr pueden
regular una increíble variedad de
funciones corporales desde la sensación
hasta el crecimiento e incluso la
respuesta hormonal